Es geht los!
Es ist das erste Mal seit 1972, dass wir wieder
zum Mond fliegen.
Und mit dabei wird ein Weltraumtourist sein.
Elon Musks Raumfahrtunternehmen SpaceX hat
das jetzt angekündigt und Elon Musk hat auch
einen Hinweis auf die Identität des ersten
Mondtouristen gegeben.
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Herzlich willkommen zu den Elon Musk Chroniken!
Erstes kommt immer alles anders und zweitens
als man denkt.
Schon vor geraumer Zeit hatte SpaceX den Flug
zum Mond angekündigt.
Doch daraus wird wohl nichts.
SpaceX hatte damals den Mondflug mit einer
bemannten Dragonkapsel verkündet.
Das ist die wiederverwendbare Kapsel, die
bereits jetzt regelmäßig die Internationale
Raumstation mit Equipment, Verbrauchsgütern
und Nahrung versorgt.
Die Crew Dragon wird zum ersten Mal bemannt
mit den Astronauten Robert Behnken und Douglas
Hurley im April 2019 zur Internationalen Raumstation
fliegen.
Behnken war bisher bei zwei Spaceshuttlemissionen
Missionsspezailsit.
Hurley nahm auch an zwei Shuttelmissionen
teil und war Pilot des letzten Spaceshuttlefluges
am 8.
Juli 2011.
Doch die Crew Dragon ist jetzt offenbar für
Mondflüge erstmal nicht geplant, sonder es
geht direkt mit der BFR, der Big Falcon Rocket
oder wie Musk sie gerne nennt, der Big Fucking
Rocket.
Sie ist zum ersten Mal wieder seit der Saturn
V höher als 100 Meter und damit die größte
aktuell existierende Rakete, wenn sie denn
fertig gebaut sit.
Aber da ist SpaceX ja extrem schnell mit der
Entwicklung.
Gerade wurde die neue Version der Falcon 9
vorgestellt, die Falcon Heavy ist erfolgreich
gestartet und jetzt geht es konkret an die
BFR.
Und sie kann mit Daten aufweisen, die ainfach
nur sensationell sind.
106 Meter ist die Gesamthöhe mit den Antriebsstufen.
2019 soll sie fertig entwickelt sein.
Die BFR ist wiederverwendbar, um die Kosten
niedrig zu halten.
Das ist ja sowieso der Kasusknacksus von SpaceX.
Das Unternehmen hat es geschafft Raumfahrt
deutlich billiger zu machen.
Fast alle der Teile der Rakete, bis auf die
zweite Stufe können wiederverwendet werden.
Und das wird auch so bei der BFR sein.
Hier dürfte sogar die zweite Stufe, die offenbar
auch während das Raumfluges als Antrieb dient,
wieder einsetzbat sein.
Mit jedem Flug kann die BFR 100 Menschen plus
Fracht in 40 Kabinen fliegen.
Die BFRs sind zusätzlich mit großen Gemeinschaftsbereichen,
Frachträumen und so weiter ausgestattet.
Wenn jetzt Musk mit diesem riesigen Raumschiff
nur einen einzigen Menschen zum Mond fliegen
will läßt das viele Fragen offen.
Was ist die restlich Fracht des Raumschiffes.
Wird der erste Tank mit Treibstoff für einen
Flug zum Mars in den Erdorbit gebracht?
Dann das ist der Plan für Musks Marsflüge.
Zuerst werden Treibstoffdepots im Erdorbit
angelegt um dann dort BFRs nach dem Start
von der Erde wieder mit Treibstoff zu befüllen
und dann damit zum Mars zu schicken.
Oder ist der Tourist, der am Montag bekannt
gegeben wird nur der erste von 100 Touristen?
Es wird extrem spannend.
Jedenfalls hat Musk schon einen Hinweis auf
den Passagier gegeben.
Gefragt, ob er es selbst sein wird, hat er
als Antwort eine japanische Flagge getwittert.
Es muss also eine super reiche Japanerin oder
ein superreicher Japaner sein.
Wer hat eine Idee?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare!
Und jetzt: Könnt ihr Clixoom weiter werbefrei
machen!
Keine Prerolls mehr.
Mit eurer Hilfe.
Immer wenn wir entsprechend viele Kanalmitglieder
gewonnen haben, schalten wir die Werbung vor
jeweils einem Video im Monat ab.
Das erste Video gibt es schon und es werden
mehr.
Werdet also Mitglied!
Hier unter dem Video draufklicken und bekommt
noch exklusive Extravideos, exklusive Livestreams
und noch ein paar weitere Privilegien!
Einen riesen Dank an all diejenigen, die schon
dabei sind!!
Wenn ihr immer garantiert über aktuelle Videos
informiert werden wollt, dann added mich übrigens
bei WhatsApp.
Dann bekommt ihr den Link zum Video vor allen
anderen von mir persönlich auf euer Handy.
Einfach hier draufklicken.
Hier geht es weiter mit (dafür drauf auch
klicken) „Mondstation: Standort gefunden!“
Bis dann, bleibt dran!